hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in his examination of Plato's allegory
of the cave in plato's doctrine of truth
Martin Heidegger is going to provide us
with a really interesting interpretation
of what has been translated as the form
of the good the idea to Agatha which is
if you remember at the apex of the
entire allegory both in the sense of
where everything is driving towards and
in in terms of the narrative the idea of
the good is like the Sun that shines
forth on everything else radiating
warmth bringing it to life so how does
this this idea of the good figure in
Heidegger tells us first of all that we
have to be very careful not to have the
wrong interpretation of what idea and
what good means here so it's not a
representation of the good he says if we
follow modern philosophy and think the
essence of the idea is percept Co
subjective representation then in the
idea of the good we find a value present
somewhere in itself of which in addition
we have an idea and he says that's a
totally wrongheaded way of understanding
it so what should we do instead he also
cautions us against understanding the
good don't worry about the idea of the
good yet but just the good till Agathon
he says the ancient Greeks did not
understand it simply as what we moderns
tend to call the moral good as opposed
to other things that we might signify as
good they had a broader category no of
course there are distinctions you know
think about Aristotle distinguishing
between the the good you might say the
intrinsically good or the beautiful the
honorable talked alone the pleasurable
the useful you know the just all these
sorts of things but in any case
Heidegger is saying for the ancient
Greeks it doesn't just mean the moral
good and it definitely doesn't mean
value in the modern
option he says we it's not moral good
because it conforms to the moral law
this interpretation falls outside of
Greek thought although Plato's
interpretation of the Agathon as idea
does offer the occasion of thinking
about the good morally and ultimately
for reckoning it to be of value says
this notion of value that came into
fashion in the 19th century in the wake
of the modern conception of truth here's
what he says is the last and at the same
time the weakest offspring of Agathon
how did the ancient Greeks understand
the auga thawne then the good
well according to Heidegger there's two
parts to this one is understanding it as
what is capable of something good as
capacity as the ability to bring
something about so you know music is a
good in part because it brings about
whatever it is that music does our
emotional responses brings about harmony
entertains us moves us right the Harper
is a good buy by doing that the
instrument that they play a pod we could
go on but here's something even more
important the good not only is that
which is able to do something able to
accomplish something able to bring
something else about able to modify
itself it's also something that enables
another to be capable of something so
this is not just the useful good this is
where you know certain very important
goods enable us think about wisdom what
is it wisdom enable us to do what his
wisdom enable others to do what does
justice enable us to do we could go on
and on and on and so Heidegger says this
is a a fundamental conception of the
good he says in Greek thought so Agathon
means that which is capable of something
and enables another to be capable of
something now if we turn to Plato's own
thought well what is good it's going to
be the idea as Agathon the idea
something good because what is the idea
- he says every idea the visible form of
something provides a look at what a
being is in every case in Greek thinking
the ideas enable something to appear in
its what miss so that's an important
thing it allows them to appear as
something it allows beings to actually
be what they are but it also provides
them with a kind of stability it allows
them to be present not just as a moment
but it's something that we can rely upon
something that we can come to take on
with in relation to ourself as something
by itself good right so he goes on and
he says the ideas are what allow things
to be themselves ideas both have a
capacity to shine forth on their own
account the idea of you know clothing
item or tie whatever whatever it happens
to be shines forth on its own account we
grasp that through our mind but it also
allows other things to be what they are
for us to understand them for us to
relate themselves or ourselves to them
we understand according to Plato this
tie as tie precisely because of the idea
or form of time and likewise for every
other physical object that we can think
of likewise even for things that we
might say are rather intangible like the
virtues we grasp a courageous act as an
instance of courage through the idea of
courage so what impact does this have
now when we start thinking in a more
metaphysical or we might say yet more
metaphysical way about the idea of the
good the form of the good Heidegger
points out that this is understood in
this allegory and in Plato's philosophy
in general in a number of complementary
first of all it is the idea of ideas why
is it the idea of ideas as he says the
ideas are what are what would exist what
are most true for Plato so there is an
idea bringing all of them together he
says here we go the ideas are what in
everything are what is in everything
that is therefore what makes every idea
be capable as an idea remember what it
is to be good is not only to be capable
of something but to make other things
capable what gives these ideas their
energy what gives these ideas their
permanence what makes these ideas be
ideas the idea of ideas the form of
forms so he says what makes every idea
be capable as an idea consists in making
possible the appearing in all its
visibility of everything present so the
idea of ideas is that which enables as
such that which makes everything else
capable that which is tall Agathe own as
such that which is the good per se and
he says that this is what makes the
ideas themselves shine forth so it lies
behind that all of them you might say he
also talks about it as being highest in
a hierarchy what kind of hierarchy he
says the good may be called the highest
idea by being the highest in the
hierarchy of making possible seeing it
is a very arduous task of looking
straight upward in in the allegory but
also in in the act of contemplation and
then he says despite the difficulty of
properly grasping it this idea is
somehow always consistently in view
whenever any beings show themselves so
the people in the bottom of the cave who
are just seeing shadows are in some very
very dim way
still grasping the idea of the good the
idea of ideas even though there is far
separated from it as we could imagine at
least in the scope of the allegory
likewise those of us who live in this
this lit world above even though we
don't realize that we're constantly in
relation to this idea of ideas that is
allowing the ideas to shine forth in
Plato's view he also talks about it in
another way that is complementary to
this says it's shining radiates warmth
and by this glowing enables everything
that comes to be to go forth in the
visibility of it what he calls its
stable duration so this is a very
important idea it's not enough just to
provide intelligibility to bring beings
into being and keep them in being that
is the function of the Sun in the
allegory or the idea of the good the
form of the good in its interpretation
so Heidegger goes on and says once the
Sun is truly seen or to drop the
metaphor once the highest ideas caught
sight of then we can draw the conclusion
that gathered together from the highest
idea itself that for all people this
idea of the good is the original source
both of all that is right all that's
correct
morally right and of all that's
beautiful so he says the highest idea we
have to understand it this way it is the
original source it is the arasaka in
German right the the originating thing
the originating we might say matter of
all things zackin all things and their
thickness
there's zack height so it's not only
allowing the things to be what they are
and maintaining them and being its
granting them their very thing in this
as well this is a
very important principle here then so he
draws a very interesting conclusion here
about what the allegory of the cave is
supposed to be doing it's supposed to
orient us towards this idea of the good
according to Plato now is it just so
that we can lose ourselves in
contemplation of the good oh it's a
wonderful I'll never think about
anything else again no
Heidegger talks about the fact and he's
getting this from Plato that what the
allegory of the cave is about is
education but education towards what he
calls prudential insight informing
practical activity they says as regards
all form of Prudential insight and
forming practical activity Falls if
follows from the essence of the highest
idea that anyone who's concerned to act
with Prudential insight must have this
in view whoever wants to act and has to
act in a world determined by the ideas
which are themselves already goods must
grasp the idea of ideas must grasp the
idea that makes them be ideas so the
very essence of Paideia he says consists
in making the human being free and
strong for the clarity and constancy of
insight into essence what is that
ultimately going to be grasping the
ideas and grasping or the forms and
grasping the idea of the good so that's
what the role of the Platonic form of
the good plays here and and Heidegger
notes that look in order to really
understand this we we have to get away
from these modern somewhat you know
anemic ways of understanding what the
good is and we have to return to a more
primal conception of it that enables us
to understand what the form of the good
is doing in this story that Plato is
telling
you